foreign
North Carolina what's up D
hey how you doing buddy we're getting it
man how about you
the same same awesome what's up my man
how can I help
uh well
I'm having some issues uh
I I I could use some advice on having
how to navigate things
um
[Music]
over 600 pounds uh I was almost 700
um
I lost 300 pounds probably almost 10
years ago and uh I ended up putting it
back on
and uh
it got and I was working at a factory
I started getting really bad plantars
fasciitis you know
and it kind of It kind of led me to have
to leave that job
and uh I ended up putting on like 50
more pounds than I originally had and uh
uh everything everything is just a mess
right now
um
like um I still live at home with my mom
um I'm 42 years old
uh
um I I I work uh
let's see
24 hours a month at a part-time job
and even there I have to have
I have to have assistance doing things
and um I'm just at a at a at a low point
to where there's so much going on
that needs fixing
that I don't even know where to start
yeah man
oh yeah
sorry no don't be sorry brother
yeah I just I don't know where that I
don't know where I would uh
I don't know I I would I know that I
would probably be homeless within a few
weeks
uh but I don't know I'm just
just kind of lost
um
I've had you know people
you know try to help me and everything
and uh I feel like I'm just
I'll let everybody down
and um
I don't know I'm just uh
I'm kind of bitter about my old self
whenever I was
whenever I lost all of my weight and
everything
um
life was just really starting to get
good
and uh
I don't know
and uh so let me ask you this my brother
what do you want to be different
snap your fingers for me you snap your
fingers for me right now
what would be different
I wouldn't be independent
what does that mean
that's a fantasy that's like unicorns
what tell me exactly what that looks
like uh I would have my own place okay I
would I would have a car again I lost my
car back in September okay
yeah you get repoed or do you wreck it
yeah it got repoed okay
and uh
I would I would have enough money to be
able to uh
support myself okay
um and be able to help my friends out
when they needed it
uh
I'll be able to love people better
um
I'd be able to be the friend that people
need
uh you know you know who
man
they don't make hearts like you anymore
Doug
nah man I'm being serious that's my
promise on this show I promise I'm gonna
tell you the truth and I'll be I'll be
I'll be hard on you in a minute but
I need you to hear me say man
like
that is not the answer I was expecting
you got a heart you're
gold pulses through your veins my
brother
foreign
the person that you have to make friends
with first
is who
myself and I I can't even stand to look
at myself I know you can I know you
can't I know you can't
when's the last time you had human touch
in your life somebody other than your
mom how's your hand
a hug or something
yeah
um
oh gosh from somebody else
I can count on one hand all right
since 2020 I can count on one hand and
probably still have plenty of fingers
left up
so I'm gonna ask you a hard question
okay
are you done
what do you mean
well it sounds like you've reached
a decision-making point
and either way you're going to be done
yeah are you done with
the first 42
it's half time
you just got your butt kicked in the
first half but y'all gonna regroup
in the locker room you're gonna come out
for the second half firing on all
cylinders
so are you done living this life that
you got
yeah or are you done like I'm cashing
out man
I'm just cashing out
that's it
[Applause]
I'm gonna be the first
just cashing out things
you know
it's it's certainly the easiest thing
it is because I know I know there is
this is going to be
like a big
gosh I can't keep myself together
I knew it was going to be a big fight
um
but uh
but the war is with one person
yeah the war's with Doug
yeah
and the beauty of going to war with
yourself is you don't have to fight
yeah right
yeah
here's here's what I want you to say I
heard you rattle off weight autonomy I
want my own place I want to be able to
serve my buddies again I can't work very
much and even when I do I'm embarrassed
and I feel ashamed I gotta get help
doing this stuff
um haven't haven't been hugged or
haven't held somebody's hand in years
right
depressed low all that stuff
your job isn't to try to fix all these
things at the same time
okay
your job is to slowly inch by inch be
calm somebody that Doug is proud of
yeah now here's the cool thing
you have lived a life the last decade
that I am not strong enough to have
lived
you have done immeasurably hard things
simply moving through the world
navigating the world things that I do on
a daily basis that I don't even give one
second of thought to
is a Monumental task it's something that
takes High coordination and high
intentionality just to do it
yeah like moving 30 feet even that's
what I'm talking about it tastes like a
nuclear reactor to get my legs to move
that's that's what I'm saying
so listen to me
you are infinitely
stronger than I am
the question I have for you and it's an
old dumb internet question you probably
heard a thousand times
which hard are you gonna choose man
because the life you live right now is
really really hard
and losing 400 pounds will be really
hard
yeah right it's both end
so it's not a matter of one being easy
it's not a matter of one being simple
simpler than the other it's a matter of
which harder you're going to choose
because you got hard in front of you
right
unless you just quit and I'm gonna tell
you right now
you're not gonna quit
no because they don't make hearts like
yours and I need you in this crazy
screwed up world we live in because I
got two little kids that are counting on
people like you to make a difference so
you don't get to quit Fair
yeah definitely you believe me when I
tell you that
yeah yeah
okay
Doug doesn't get to quit Doug just has
to choose his heart man
yeah and like sometimes
like
I think uh
I don't know like whenever I lost all
that weight you know
sometimes
that is the only thing that gives me
hope is because I know I can do it of
course you can
so there's not a doubt in my mind
now can I be hard on you for a second
yeah
what kind of role does your mom play
someone's got to be getting you all the
food someone's got to be bringing all
this stuff to you somebody has a vested
interest in you staying down is that
your mom
yeah like I'm I'm living off of like 400
not even 400 a month so the person who
is taking care of you
is also using you to make herself feel
better is that right
yeah I mean she she's the
shoulder issue I mean she can't do a lot
so no no I'm talking about who's
bringing you all this food dog
it's
I guess it's just a combined effort uh
I mean we go to the food pantry when uh
they load us up
they give us uh whatever we can get you
know okay
but uh you have the internet at home
oh yeah do you have Instagram
yeah all right you have a pin in front
of you
um
or you can type it into your phone okay
I want you to write down the name Ethan
souply
e t h a n s u p l e e
okay all right
when we get off this call I want you to
subscribe to his Instagram page
and I want you to go down a rabbit hole
reading every post that he writes
reading all of the captions that he
writes okay
he's in one of my favorite actors who's
ever lived and I've never met the guy
but I've been so moved by his
transformation
foreign
from who he was to who he is now
and I think you all have
he'll be able to speak authentically
into you okay
before we get off the phone
we're gonna do a couple of things all
right
okay thing number one
do you re would you read a book if I
send it to you for free
oh yeah all right I'm gonna send you my
book for free
I'm also going to send you my buddy Dave
Ramsey's book Total Money Makeover for
free
oh I'm also I'm gonna send you
my company's Flagship product Financial
Peace University that teaches you how to
deal with money I'm gonna send that to
you for free too all the videos and
everything okay oh wow but listen I know
that you're going well got any money to
even know how to manage you will you
will
okay
yeah
but here's what I want you to start
experiencing is microscopic little wins
teeny tiny little wins
now yeah if I'm you I would go hire a
coach I would hire a therapist I would
do all you don't have that access right
now because for financial constraints
correct
exactly okay you live in a snapshot of
History
where the greatest Minds on the planet
are putting things up for free workout
plans nutrition plans ideas ways to
communicate with themselves or just
putting it up for free
okay
I want you
to begin to be your own best Advocate
and you never have been Doug and it's
got to start today
oh okay so yeah
I'm not in a nutrition expert I'm not
someone who can walk you through how do
you where do you even start if you weigh
620 pounds that information exists on
online okay yeah but you have to be
determined to go get it
yeah
and that starts with doing something
really important okay yeah you have to
change the identity man
from an overweight obese loser who still
lives with his mom who can't even work
and so people have to help him
you gotta change your identity too I'm a
guy who loves Doug
and I'm a guy who treats Doug with
respect and dignity
and respect and dignity means I don't
poison myself anymore both psychologic
mentally and physically with food
I'm Doug and I believe in something
bigger than myself
I've lived for decades as an obese man
and I can do hard things I'm just gonna
have to do different hard things
yeah
do you believe me
yeah yeah
oh man
oh
I just threw a bunch at you what do you
think
am I full of crap are you are you in no
I'm in oh man
oh
I'm definitely yeah what's your weight
number today
uh last last I weighed it was like 6 27.
okay
once you get on a plan
an actual plan
when that number Hits gets a four in
front
I want you to take a picture of that
scale and email it into the show and I'm
going to send you a check for a thousand
dollars how about that
oh wow okay
Fair
yeah that sounds Beyond Fair all right
also I'm Gonna Get You six months of
free counseling with my friends at
betterhelp
oh wow okay you're gonna have to talk to
somebody but dude you gotta do it
yeah
yeah okay right
um yeah right
like I've tried to get uh like Medicaid
and stuff like that I know I got you
well I don't I don't have I don't have
you on the physical stuff
but I can take care of the other stuff
for a season Okay so
I want you to talk to a counselor it's
digital so you can do it from your phone
you can do it from your laptop sitting
in your house you don't have to go
anywhere
these are real licensed therapist and I
got you for six months cool wow yeah
definitely
and when you're when your number on your
scale has a three in front of it can be
399.9
I'm going to send you a free dream Cloud
king-sized mattress change your life
oh wow cool wow
so this is what deloni I'm calling your
bluff brother
all right if you're in we'll walk with
you
yeah let's do it okay
yeah yeah
you promise
I do
all right
I love you Doug
thank you buddy I love y'all I
appreciate y'all
no you didn't hear me you rolled it off
because you don't you you you are so
grossed out by Doug you can't even hear
it
Doug I love you and I'm grateful for you
and I'm glad you're here
thank you okay
this does not start tomorrow this starts
today
yeah
it starts right now
yeah you head down the rabbit hole I
want you to have a pin and a little
notebook with you next to you and I want
you to write down the things from
Ethan's Instagram page that that means
something to you
May reach out to him he may not respond
because he's kind of a big deal but he's
just got so many people following him
but listen
the journey starts today not tomorrow
and that might be five tiny little
exercises
that's day one
that might be five tiny little here's
five things I like about duck even you
it might take you a while but you're
gonna get there
yeah
here are five changes I'm gonna make
with the food I put in my body and not
something stupid like I'm only eating
one meal that's not sustainable we're
changing our life now yeah yeah cool
yeah very
all right
we'll walk alongside you man but you
gotta lead the way
you in uh yeah are you giving up on me
no I don't know sorry hey I'll give you
a hell no on this one Doug I'll give it
to you
all right okay okay yeah yeah
all right hang on the line and we'll get
you hooked up my brother I'm proud of
you think oh thank you thank you thank
you for calling proud of you
and uh man I can't wait to see that
would be the happiest thousand dollar
check I ever write in my life I can't
wait you in yeah yeah I'm in excellent
excellent excellent excellent